Joe digenova is a former US Attorney for
the District of Columbia and he joins us
now I just want to state at the outset
Joe
he lied said the news anchors he lied
and he deserves whatever's coming to him
assess that claim if you would he did
not lie and in fact the FBI knew it
let's remember what this is about
this was a pretextual crime created by
the FBI and by Sally Yates the acting
Attorney General remember after the
election Hillary Clinton needed a reason
why she lost
enter Russian collusion part of that was
to find somebody in the administration
to frame for talking to the Russians
they found general Flynn but in fact all
of general Flynn's conversations with
Russian ambassador and everybody else
were legal so why did the FBI approach
him they knew what he said they knew it
was legal the answer is they wanted to
frame him and they succeeded and he did
not tell them false information some of
it may have been paused it may have been
nuanced
he did not lie and indeed the agents who
actual 302s are available said he didn't
lie and it's interesting that Muller did
not turn over the original 302s
to judge Sullivan today he turned over
an interview of agents truck which was
done months later by Muller's people the
answer is Michael Flynn was framed in
order to get at Donald Trump Sally Yates
James Comey Peter struck Andy McCabe all
planned it what you are watching play
out in an American courtroom is one of
the most disgraceful events in American
criminal justice and everybody on
Muller's team should be ashamed of
themselves and none of them should ever
be allowed to go back in to the
Department of Justice and any attorney
who advised Michael Flynn to plead
guilty to this rather than going public
with the frame-up that was happening to
him ought to be I think disbarred let me
ask you that what do you make of the
reaction to it I think a lot of people
watching even this channel pretty
well-informed news consumers are
surprised to learn that the crime here
the only crime here arises from that
interview the lawyer 'less interview in
the White House did Mike Flynn was never
charged with colluding with anybody
including the Turks you've heard all
this speculation
now he's working for her - Juan he was
never charged with any of that and yet
he's totally been destroyed as a man his
family's been crushed they're bankrupted
to sell their house on the basis of that
one crime why doesn't anybody on any
other network say wait a second could it
be slightly disproportionate well Tucker
the people on the other networks and the
people at the FBI at that time in the
Department of Justice wanted one thing
they wanted to find a way to destroy
Donald Trump because he wasn't supposed
to be elected but he beat them and once
they were beaten they got angry and then
they got vindictive and then they got
vindictive by using the criminal justice
system weaponizing it and John Brennan
at the CIA and James clapper followed
through on their promise threat to
figure out a way to get the people that
they didn't want elected in order to
make up for the fact that she Hillary
Clinton had lost this has become one
that one of the greatest scandals in the
history of our country and the media is
ignoring it and it is it is it is truly
important that what you are doing by
focusing on these stories continue to be
done until there's a new Attorney
General and there can be a grand jury to
find out who was it that leaked the
conversation of Michael Flynn with the
Russian ambassador that was a crime the
leak to David Ignatius of the Washington
Post exposing general Flynn's
conversation with the Russian ambassador
was a crime and the question tonight is
why isn't that crime being investigated
because everyone in Washington is deeply
invested in our failed foreign policy
and anybody who suggests changing the
foreign policy that they're deeply
invested in and get rich from gets
crushed as you know George a gentleman
thank you thank you